the virus is trending in the wrong
direction
hardly any time after strong measures
were taken
to stop it doing exactly that the r
number for the uk rose this week
to 0.9 to 1. it's still under one which
is crucial
but it's closer to one than it was
before now obviously this picture isn't
uniform
in the northeastern yorkshire previously
the danger areas
are is now well below one but it could
be above one
in london and the east of england is the
prime minister warned
today the problem is more now than this
is very very important
you're seeing it taking off in london
and the south east particularly as you
know in in the kent
area that's extremely worrying
we re these numbers are going in the
wrong direction in the south
obviously we know it's not good news if
the r is one or above
but to understand what that means in
context it's helpful to look at this
graph
from the office for national statistics
you can see infections in england
are slowing but not very fast
and they're still relatively high now
having
r1 means you effectively just carry on
at this level up here
you're basically accepting a certain
level of cases
and hospital emissions and sadly deaths
when r is one the absolute level matches
a great deal and unfortunately this
lockdown which started about there
didn't do that nearly as much as the
first
here's the same graph for wales and you
can see the lockdown didn't put
it push infections down in a lasting way
here either
it certainly had an effect it paused
infections but look over here they
rebounded
really sharply even though the official
r
is about one you can see why mark draft
has said that it could be as high as 1.4
and why he's warning there might be
tough new measures
to come if the strengthened
measures of last week and the extra
actions
of this week together with the efforts
each and every one of us need
to make if those measures do not succeed
in turning the tide of the virus
then it is inevitable that we will have
to consider
a move to alert level 4
immediately after christmas
alert level 4 in wales is basically
equivalent to lockdown
the english government really wants to
avoid that so it has a
different answer to the problem of
writing infections
mass testing but that has issues
i've got hold of a leaked copy of the
first
official assessment of the mass testing
pilot in liverpool
it's not a scientific study but it does
contain some
very interesting findings here's the key
slide
and it has some stark warnings it says
the hardest to reach people that's with
lft
that's with these new rapid lateral flow
tests
the hardest to reach were young male
deprived and digitally excluded
and the uptake was almost
twice in the least deprived decile
compared with the most deprived
in other words the richest people got
twice as many tests as the poorest and
experts i spoke to
said these screening programs were for
affluent people who wanted reassurance
not people who really needed testing
we asked the department for health if
they wanted to comment and they didn't
get back to us
but with 67 local authorities expected
to start testing soon
the government is placing a lot of
weight on mass testing
it's their answer to the hardest
question of all of this
how do you stop covid without
going into lockdown